todas las mañanas juanjo se florean sale
a entrenar en esta bicicleta adaptada a
su cuerpo y con la que recorre cientos
de kilómetros
y su esposa es su entrenadora y también
su apoyo en la carretera juan jose fue
soldado del ejército de colombia pero
también uno de tantos menores de edad
reclutados por la guerrilla en julio de
2011 un paquete fue dejado en la casa de
su madre era una bomba enviada por las
farc producto de una extorsión
el explosivo detonó en las manos de juan
jose estuvo en coma le practicaron
múltiples cirugías duró un año en
rehabilitación física y durante este
proceso descubrió el ciclismo y el
placer de nadar
sueño con ser el campeón paralímpico o
campeón del mundo
y ser campeón de las copas del mundo de
esa la ambición más grande que tengo
entonces por eso esa razón de entrenar y
exigirme cada día
al principio no fue fácil aceptar su
cuerpo e incluso un día pensó en que no
quería vivir más pero angie llegó a su
vida y formaron una familia ella lo
impulsa a salir todos los días e incluso
han creado una marca de material
deportivo yo quisiera que nosotros tres
formamos un equipo de mediana de primero
porque
nosotros lo el niño y yo lo apoyamos él
o sea a que él salga a todos los días
con alegría con pasión a hacer su
trabajo a montar en bicicleta
juanjo se acumula medallas de
competencias ganadas en años anteriores
su meta ahora es llegar a los
paralímpicos de toque en 2021 y si no lo
logra su objetivo será parís en 2024